make food with your family and your
parents it's it really brings you back
home hi I'm sweaty and I'm reduce
Westies mom and today we're making aloo
and bourree bourree is a fried dough
bread what's great about the bori is
that it's so accessible all the
ingredients there's only three of them
and they're available anywhere it's just
flour oil and water my first time making
40 was in middle school I wanted to
learn how to make it I've always liked
making food so I wanted to learn
traditional foods the way you know that
your dough is done is your fingers
nothing that stick to your fingers so
once the dough is ready you take a damp
towel and you covered the dough just so
the dough doesn't dry out so this is
funny Indian saying and it's basically
if your Forry is round you know that
your husband is going to be happy with
you in the future and it looks like my
husband's not going to be too happy with
me because I can't make the round
worried to save my life so have many
fond memories of cooking with swathi you
would look in at the booties being
picked up and she would go oh look at
that I would like to do it one day mommy
and she was just poor at that time I was
typically a vegetarian dish in ours we
make it a little soupy ER and there's
potatoes tomatoes peas spices onions you
have a little bit of everything there I
think our audience to try this recipe
because it's awesome it's tasty it's
flavorful it's everything you want
usually we make this aloo sabzi with
green chilies just to give it that extra
heat but my daughter's was they never
liked heat so I have learned to cook
without any chili she loves it as do we
yeah baby kind of Indian am I can't
handle spicy food today's experience was
great I got to play with some balls with
my mom I don't get to do that often
because you know she doesn't live here
we did a lot of bonding and I cracked a
lot of bad jokes so most of my life I've
been raised in California and doing
things like this really connects me back
to my roots because even though I go
back and visit India it's not the same
as living there so when you do things
like make food with your family and your
parent
it's it really brings you back home and
you get to taste these flavors in your
own kitchen looks like as if you were
there oh yes
[Music]
[Music]